hey youtubers is Charlie so we're still
filming the flash episode one for that
comic-con trailer but we got
confirmation on a couple new characters
that are actually pretty cool so let's
do a breakdown there's a new round of
the flash ring giveaway all you have to
do to enter is be a subscriber leave a
comment on this video so it looks like
they're almost done with week 1 on the
flash so that's why you haven't seen
Barry on set there been a couple set
pics Wally's still wearing the yellow
costume like we all believed it was that
video I did a couple days ago about
costume upgrades yeah Barry will get a
few costume upgrades but when people
were asking Kid Flash about the red
version of the costume the quote that I
read from the actor that plays Wally
West was basically him saying that it's
not quite on his radar yet really the
only reason he stopped wearing it in the
comics was because he stopped being the
Kid Flash and just became the flash they
might be introducing a new character in
this first episode but there are still a
couple more days to go so when they
announced the title was going to be the
flash reborn it was basically day 1 of 8
that was on the fourth of July means
they're going to be shooting to
Wednesday so if we actually do see Grant
Gustin walking around on set I'm not
expecting you to happen til the middle
of the week like he might show up at the
very very end and even if he does it
might be indoors so just don't be
surprised if you don't see Barry walking
around in his costume
but because Comic Con is a couple weeks
away we will see them filming episode 2
behind the scenes so that would be a
more likely place for Barry to pop up
the new character this allows you guys a
little crazy because they might be
introducing elongated man or just a
couple other comic book characters that
show up at carnivals because there is a
big carnival set that they're filming on
right now and there been a couple
notable carnival stories in the flash
the first one was during the Jay Garrick
era during flash number 36 where you run
into the Peter Merkel character his
power is that he just has like crazy
contortionist abilities he's a hypnotist
he's a really good thief there's a small
chance very small chance that they could
be introducing the elongated man through
the Backson Brothers Circus during the
Barry Allen era back in the 80s flash
vol 2 96
elongated man gets captured by the
Backson Brothers Circus and there's a
bunch of different members called
zero orcas scrunch and blubber if they
are going to use those characters they
would probably change blubber just
because her superpower is being super
fat and I can already hear people
complaining about that but what happens
is is there a circus team with
relatively slight of hand abilities like
they can hypnotize people they capture
Ralph dim B is misdirection so that they
can steal interferon to help their
friends so first they seem pretty
sinister like they're stealing
interferon but you're like why are they
stealing medicine from all these
different labs so while the flash is
trying to rescue elongated man find out
where he's being held they grab a big
score in Central City from a lab then
the flash finds Ralph Denby elongated
man who's been hypnotized to think that
he's actually part of the carnival and
he's like a contortionist all wrapped up
into a pretzel
so they team up and it becomes this
really funny way of using the elongated
man's powers flash uses his cyclone
ability to turn elongated man into a
projectile they take down the criminals
but then they find out that they had
been stealing all this medicine to help
their friend the vaccin brothers are
able to help their friend he stops
looking like the Elephant Man he comes
out looking normal and everybody's happy
remember back at the beginning of season
two they opened with that big
celebration last day it was kind of a
carnival of sorts
[Applause]
[Music]
they try to open the season on really
happy moment they don't want to open it
on a bummer because you got 22 more
episodes they want people to be really
pumped up about the rest of the season
but just like they introduce villains
every season they introduce good
characters so don't be surprised if they
cycle Julian out for elongated man in
but none of that's confirmed just
speculation based on the scenes that it
looks like they're filming so we'll find
out about that at Comic Con anyway and
we might actually see an elongated man
running around on set so just keep your
eyes peeled they've also been really
weird pictures of samurai on set so
there's actually a big crossover story
called the flying samurai where the
flash and iris West go to Japan and they
face Baron katana who has a bunch of
robot Samurai so this might be unrelated
to the carnival stuff that's happening
so it looks like they're going to be
showing a bunch of different adventures
that Wally has had while Barry has been
gone because you see Cisco helping them
out here so don't be surprised that the
episode jumps around in time a lot
there's been a little bit of video from
the set via sem máscara Bound just a
Twitter user that I think was camping
the set along with YVR shoots sort of
like your typical Vancouver set people
that just capture a lot of this stuff so
here's that video
[Music]
this looks like it has more to do with
them fighting the robot samurais than
with them biting the carnival people but
it'll be interesting to see how those
stories cross over or if they take place
during different time periods well let
me know in the comments what do you
think the flash is doing with the
carnival do you think they're actually
going to do this elongated man crossover
story and it'll be like Wally's story
even though it was from the Barry Allen
era and then much later after that
adventure the flash is reborn because it
sounds like what's going to happen for
most of episode one is that Wally's
going to be the flash there's this
picture of him with vibe on the set so
they're taking down whatever criminals
are going down iris and Wally seems like
they're back to being the flash point
brother-sister crime-fighting team so we
know that they're around we know that
Caitlin is around for the entire episode
so it'll be interesting to see if she's
come back to team flash or if she's
still working on her own because there
are a couple ways I think they could
introduce her using this elongated man's
story that don't require her to be in
STAR Labs but the other big news is the
show just hired a new writer who's a big
comic book person so if you've never
heard of him sterling Gates has written
Superman Justice League the vibe comic
book for a long time he actually took
over the vibe comic book from Andrew
Kreisberg who's the showrunner on the
flash he also wrote the mr. mitzvahs pit
lick episode of Supergirl so it is fun
to see comic book writers come and write
the flash and the other TV shows but
they actually did cycle out one of their
show runners so if you didn't like the
way they wrote the flash last season
they've actually had some creative
changes behind the scenes so it'll be
interesting to see what it looks like
this season because it does seem like
it's going to be more rogue heavy
especially given that the thinkers such
a big character what'll happen is is
Stephen Amell was teasing a bunch of
stuff for arrow season 6 he confirmed
Deathstroke is going to be a huge
character and show up a bunch of times
so I'll do a video for the teaser that
he dropped that'll post in a couple
hours but leave all your requests in the
comments below
congratulations to Charles Walker you're
the latest giveaway winner please
private message me on the back end of my
channel so I can get your contact
details while you wait for everything
click here for a brand new flash episode
one and you can click here for a new
game of Thrones trailer thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight